And just provide, this is the last of the kind of single agent menin inhibitor data
that we will go through.
And again, I can skip through the background, thanks to our previous talks, and just highlight
again that these really are different compounds.
They are all quite similar, as if domino has more of a different structure, but then you
can look at, you know, the different bonds encircled with enzominib is the fact that
it's an amide bond.
And really the point of this slide is kind of talking about enzominib specifically in
terms of how it was designed to hopefully have a lower lipophilicity, so that you have
kind of more rapidly clearing drug without the same accumulation.
And highlighted here, it goes through it again.
So you have enzominib in green, and then you have the three other menin inhibitors that
are listed in purple, blue, and yellow.
And you'll, so the half-life of enzominib is shorter, right?
It's a BID drug.
It's two to three hours without azoles.
It's about three to four hours with azoles, so it's not identified to have strong SIP
interaction, but yet actually that's based on an FDA definition that requires significant
effects, and actually the AUC does increase by about 40% when you're using enzominib with
azoles, but that doesn't reach the level of a strong interaction with minimal to no
accumulation.
And so that's what kind of the figure is showing you.
So when you look at, for instance, menin inhibitor two in blue, you see kind of less,
less accumulation, the number doesn't get quite as high, and then you have pretty rapid
intracellular washout, whereas the purple and the yellow, you have kind of a very high
levels of accumulation.
You look at the concentration and then shorter, or I'm sorry, not a less rapid washout, whereas
enzominib, you know, according to the sumitomo slides that I'm sharing, you know, is kind
of that perfect compound where you have adequate, good accumulation, and then a more rapid
washout.
Okay.
And so this is the phase one, two study design of enzominib, and I'll take you through the
monotherapy data and also the initial combination data.
These are both presented at ASH this past December.
And so starting with the monotherapy, there were 116 patients treated.
The median age was about 55, so average, a little bit younger.
And then I've highlighted, you know, prior treatments are two.
And you'll notice that three quarters of patients had had prior venetoclax, about a third had
had a transplant, 10% had had a prior menin inhibitor.
Of course, you know, this came along after rivuminib and zipdominib had already gone
through the development process.
And so some patients had already had a menin inhibitor, just over half were KMT2A rearranged
with, you know, a smattering of the various different KMT2A rearrangements.
When you look at AEs, right, we need to kind of be thinking about the AE profiles of these
different menin inhibitors.
On the left are any AEs, regardless of causality, and then on the right are what are
thought, were thought by the investigator to be related to enzominib.
You'll notice, you know, a decent amount of cytopenias, more of them, you know, in all
populations with, of course, relapsed leukemia.
Fewer, when you get to grade three or higher, thought to be related to enzominib.
When you look at differentiation syndrome and QT prolongation, which I've highlighted
in yellow, you do see about a 13% DS overall, with grade three or higher being about 8%.
And QT prolongation.
So, again, we're looking at about a 13% DS overall, with grade three or higher being about
8%.
And QT prolongation was described in a handful of patients, but none grade three or higher.
No DLTs on this study were identified.
So, when you look at the response rates, you may have noticed that we're going from 116
or so patients in the monotherapy down to, you know, far fewer when you're looking at
who is actually deemed to be response-evaluable.
And there's kind of a small little bullet in the bottom right saying, you know, that
you had to have received 200 BID or higher.
You had to have not had had a prior menin inhibitor.
And you had to have had excess blast to begin with.
And so, you're kind of shrinking down the number of efficacy of valuable patients.
In the KMT2A rearranged cohort, 300 BID was identified to be the recommended phase two
dose.
And you're seeing a composite CR rate, CR, CRH, CRI of 60%.
There is a bit of a difference, more with menin inhibitors than in most other AML studies
of a difference between CR, CRH and CR, CRI.
Meaning that there are a lot of patients that are responding, but that don't have adequate,
platelet count recovery.
And so, certainly, that this was also seen in enzominib, and I think is kind of an interesting
thing about menin inhibitors.
NPM1, they have not, as of this presentation, identified the recommended phase two dose.
But what they're highlighting here is that at all the doses above 200, you're seeing,
again, impressive composite remission rates.
Certainly when you're including all overall response rates, and then even the composite
CR and CR, CRH.
DR.
So, when you look at overall, all of these different, the NPM1 and KMT2A rearranged at
doses of 200 or higher, the overall CR, CRH is 44%, which as a, kind of as a number compared
to revuminib and zifdominib, which was about 20 to 25%, appears superior, but again, these
were later, this is a later study, and it's hard to compare.
Overall survival is shown here for KMT2A, NPM1, I think it's, again, you know, it's
in a monotherapy phase.
One study, it's hard to really truly know, kind of what this OS means.
But in NPM1 patients, right, that are median of two prior lines of therapy, almost everyone
has already seen venetoclax.
Gus highlighted the fact that these patients have an OS of about, you know, two to four
months really in multiple salvages.
So it does, even though you would think maybe it would be higher, this really is, is actually
an impressive number.
And then real quick, looking at the, so this is relapsed also, but relapsed now looking
at a triplet regimen.
And part one was dose finding, 140, 200, 300 BID, it moved into 300 BID as the ideal combination
with azaven.
40 patients treated, again, median range, average age is about 59 with a range.
Highlighted are the fact that, again, you've got two prior lines of therapy on average.
About a third of patients had had prior ven, about a, just over a quarter had had a prior
menin inhibitor.
And they, it is highlighted here, identifying again.
No DLTs, no treatment-related deaths, DS was lower.
When you're putting things in combination, you don't see as much DS.
Grade three or higher was zero.
Grade three or higher QT prolongation was zero.
And then looking at clinical activity, kind of across the board, even at that lower enzomative
dose of 140 BID, we're seeing really impressive responses.
Composite CRs and objective CRs kind of numbers are highlighted here and are impressive.
And then looking now at those.
Those who are ven and menin inhibitor naive, seeing a composite CR rate of over 60%.
So these numbers, of course, look quite good in a relapsed setting where people have had
two prior lines of therapy.
We talked a little bit about transplant.
About six of these patients went to transplant.
Two of the lines along the top are patients that went to transplant and were able to start
enzomative after transplant.
So certainly it does seem that some of those patients are at the top of the list.
But then again, the duration of treatment in the swimmers plot, on average, is only about
four cycles or so.
So certainly we need more follow-up time.
Two final slides to show, just to kind of compare, as we're trying to figure out what
these different drugs, they are a little bit different, right?
You will see DS across the board.
There is maybe a hint that there's less DS with Plexi and enzomative.
Or maybe it's just that we've learned menin inhibitors cause DS and we're being smarter
about managing it as these studies are happening later.
There does seem to be a difference.
In terms of QT prolongation, there doesn't seem to be as much outside of ribuminib.
And then just to kind of, this is the concluding slide, which I won't read you through.
But just highlighting the combinations are certainly encouraging in terms of responses,
maybe decreased DS and other side effects, and hopefully may help overcome some of the
monotherapy mechanisms of resistance.
Great.
Thank you.